[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis pierre-marie au
fret architecte urbaniste et aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler du ray amour des
villes alors je pars du principe que
vous avez déjà des notions en amour mais
peut-être moins en ré de ville alors
personnellement moi ça fait très
longtemps que je n'ai pas entendu un
habitant me confier qu'il était amoureux
de sa ville et ce qui me touche
particulièrement puisque cela fait à peu
près 15 ans que j'ai passé mon diplôme
et ça fait 15 ans que je travaille au
quotidien à l'amélioration de quartiers
existants ou alors la conception de
quartier nouveau donc je commence à être
un petit peu impatient mais par contre
j'ai une très forte conviction c'est
qu'il y a dans le raid ville un levier
très fort pour pouvoir améliorer la
qualité d'un quartier et la qualité de
vie de ses habitants
le raid ville on peut considérer que
c'est comme un territoire qui est
composée d' espaces bâtis le
rez-de-chaussée et des espaces ouverts
une rue une place une cour de l'espace
public et que selon le degré le niveau
d'interface que l'on arrive à créer
entre ces deux espaces
eh bien on arrive à bouger quelques
leviers qui bouge quelques paramètres
qui à leur tour contribuer à
l'amélioration d'un quartier et de ses
habitants
mais pour cela on a besoin de travailler
ensemble vous les habitants et nous les
urbanistes parce que pendant très
longtemps la ville c'était surtout une
histoire d'urbanistes et d'ailleurs
surtout une histoire d'hommes et
aujourd'hui on prend conscience qu'on a
tout intérêt à travailler en équipe très
en amont du projet urbain afin que le
projet de ville avec ses rues et ses
bâtiments qui vont être réalisés et bien
soit beaucoup plus proche des attentes
de leurs habitants puisqu'au final c'est
vous qui habitez les quartiers et pas
forcément nous alors je vais vous
expliquer dans cet exposé quel pourrait
être votre rôle dans cette histoire
le chemin est plutôt logique mais il
n'est pas forcément toujours très simple
en tout cas le jeu en vaut la chandelle
alors vous avez probablement déjà vu ses
unes de journaux il ya à peu près un
mois en mars lors de l'annoncé du
premier confinement en quelques jours
quatre cent cinquante mille parisiens
ont fui la capitale
alors il se trouve que j'avais les yeux
rivés sur la bretagne je suis breton et
il y a eu plus 1000 plus cent mille
pardons personnes à venir se confiner en
bretagne dans un contexte plus bleu un
contexte plus vert alors qu'est ce qu'on
en retient quand on conçoit une ville et
que quand ceux qui en ont la possibilité
la fuye puisque historiquement la ville
intra muros à l'intérieur de ses murs
elle était faite pour protéger ses
habitants alors s'agirait-il de rajouter
du vert et du bleu dans la ville pour
pouvoir contribuer au plaisir de ses
habitants alors certes ça y contribue
bien largement mais ça ne fait pas
complètement tout le tour de la question
alors personnellement je ne me suis pas
confiné en bretagne je suis resté chez
moi j'habite à un ancien atelier au
milieu d'une cour dans le 19e
arrondissement et j'étais assez
attentifs à la manière dont mes voisins
avaient adapter leurs modes de vie à ce
nouveau contexte un peu étrange et
notamment je me suis rendu compte que
edwige et rené mes deux voisins de 94
ans de par leur grand âge ne pouvais
plus aller se promener dans l'espace
public dans la rue vous souvenez les
restrictions était assez clair pour les
personnes d'un grand âge et donc leurs
sorties quotidiennes étaient dans notre
cour et je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
avaient eux-mêmes repéré qu'il y avait
comme une tache le soleil dans un coin
de la cour et vers 16 heures
il s'adosse est un mur en pierre et il
profitait de ses rayons de soleil avant
de remonter chez eux ils habitent le
premier étage les deux fenêtres à droite
de l'écran alors le week-end qui a suivi
cette observation avec mon copain qui
est aussi architecte on a ramassé des
planches qui traînait chez nous depuis
un dernier chantier et on les a assemblé
afin de créer un fauteuil pour edwige et
un fauteuil pour rené des fauteuils bien
larges pour qu'ils puissent passer du
temps dehors et avec un petit gadget
c'est qu'on a accroché on avis c'est un
un accroche balai pour que enfin sur le
fauteuil de rené afin qu'ils puissent y
accrocher sa canne vous savez les cannes
c'est toujours des choses qui tombent et
donc on a disposé les deux chaises à
l'endroit où ils avaient l'habitude de
faire leur pose est donc premier constat
est bien c'est que leur pause au soleil
est passé de 3 minutes quand il était
debout à 3 heures quand il était assis
ensuite ils ont commencé à descendre les
journaux pour lire les news
sauf qu'à cette époque de l'année les
news n'était franchement pas très
réjouissante et donc ils sont descendus
avec leurs mots croisés et très vite on
s'est rendu compte qu'il n'avait plus le
temps de faire leurs mots croisés vu
qu'ils étaient au milieu d'un salon
urbain et que chaque voisin descendant
dans la cour pour aller faire un tour
dans le quartier et la fameuse promenade
d'une heure qui nous étaient permises et
bien commencé la promenade par une
discussion avec edwige erronée ils nous
ont dit que ça fait j'ai pas très bien
compris ça fait 30 ans ou 60 ans qu'ils
habitent dans l'immeuble en tout cas il
n'avait jamais autant échanger avec les
voisins et en respectant bien
strictement les règles de distanciation
physique on a réussi à faire un pied de
nez à la distanciation sociale ce qui
nous faisait le plus peur dans cette
période où le repli sur soi était était
pouvait être assez dangereux et
finalement ils nous ont confié que ce
qui se passait dans la cour
leur faisait beaucoup penser à
l'ambiance dans leur petit village aux
pays-bas ce que vous avez vu qu' ils
sont basques et donc ici ici est une
tradition presque basque mais c'est une
expérience très personnelle pour moi
finalement elle ressemble beaucoup à une
autre tradition en espagne cette fois et
qui s'appelle thomas de la flèche ce cas
c'est prendre l'air frais c'est la
tradition de sortir sa chaise le soir
non pas pour prendre le soleil mais pour
prendre la fraîcheur et aussi les
nouvelles fraîches de la journée et j'ai
choisi de vous montrer cet article de la
vanguardia qui est assez amusant
puisqu'ils relatent l'histoire de
piétons qui se sont plaints auprès de la
mairie puisque les trottoirs étaient
obstrués par des personnes un peu
bavarde le soir et que les piétons ne
pouvais plus marcher
et finalement la ville april partie de
la tradition historique recommandant aux
piétons d'utiliser la chaussée et
recommandant par ailleurs à aux
automobilistes d'aller se garer en
entrée de ville alors on a ici un autre
versant durée de ville qui est plutôt
comme qui est à comparaître quand on va
chez l'acupuncteur où ils nous plantent
une aiguille dans le pied pour résoudre
un problème à l'épaule eh bien là c'est
un petit peu pareil le raid ville on
arrive on parle d'une histoire sur un
trottoir et finalement on a un impact
sur un autre espace de la vie
il comme paris s'il est comme par
exemple ici les automobilistes les
piétons
on parle des mobilités urbaines voilà
plusieurs paramètres qui sont actionnés
par rapport à quelque chose qui se passe
à l'origine à l'interface entre l'espace
bâti et l'espace ouvert mais cette
tradition très espagnole on se rend
compte qu'elle appartient à beaucoup
d'autres contextes aussi bien dans des
cultures du nord que des cultures du sud
de l'est ou de l'ouest etc à vendre être
avant d'être une tradition urbaine cela
remonterait à une tradition rurale et
donc le banc ou la chaise devant la
façade de la ferme serait donc le grand
ancêtre de la terrasse de bistrot tout
simplement avec la spécificité ici bien
parisienne que les chaises sont tournés
vers le centre de la ville vers le
centre de la chaussée
contrairement par exemple à la typologie
du pub anglais dans lequel on est plutôt
tournée vers le centre de du bar vers le
comptoir que cette image on peut
considérer que c'est comme un portrait
de ville qui re train qui retrace un
petit peu la société en 1900 à paris
alors cette image on peut considérer
aussi que c'est comme un archétype durée
de vie actif la limite entre le bâti et
l'espace ouvert la limite entre le
public et privé est presque floutés
regardez-la fixement est maintenant
faite la raisonner avec ce photomontage
de l'artiste nicolas moulin qui
s'appelle vide et paris alors je vous
pose une question est ce que paris est
toujours paris quand on lui enlève son
raid ville alors évidemment non mais
cette image on a plutôt l'impression
qu'elle fait partie d'un scénario de
science fiction et pourtant elle nie pas
si différent du contexte qui lie à 1,50
m de l'entrée de votre école à cergy
pontoise
sur ce tronçon de rue qu'est ce que l'on
observe de l'espace pour les poubelles
pour les voitures des portes de garage
des murs aveugles et des fenêtres plutôt
fermé les trottoirs sont assez étroit je
ne sais pas si deux fauteuils roulants
peuvent s'y croiser alors est ce que
cette image on l'assumé comme un
portrait de notre société en 2021
est ce que c'est ça qu'on a envie de
graver dans les manuels dans les manuels
d'histoire de la ville est ce que c'est
ça que l'on peut considérer comme un
patrimoine à léguer aux générations
futures
alors personnellement non et c'est
notamment pour ça qu'avec françois
leclercq mon ancien patron quand on a
répondu à un concours international pour
la
cité des médias à bruxelles on nous
posait la question de faire un nouveau
quartier pour 5000 nouveaux habitants et
5000 employés du monde des médias
notre réponse était de dire que le coeur
de ce nouveau quartier devait être un
espace public paysager qui serait le
connecteur de tous les programmes et de
tous les différents usagers de ce
nouveau morceau de ville et pour ça on a
mis en place une méthodologie assez
strictes dans lequel on a disséqué un à
un tous les programmes de ce nouveau
quartier une école de journalisme
une école de médias une start-up grosses
entreprises des médias un logement
social un logement pour personnes âgées
un logement étudiant et la liste est
longue et ensuite on a sélectionné tous
les mètres carrés les plus à même
d'avoir une interface plutôt active
entre le dedans et le dehors afin que
l'espace public soit habité soit animé
des programmes de rez de chaussée afin
que l'expérience du piéton et de l'usagé
de ce nouveau quartier bien soit le plus
la plus stimulante possible pendant le
parcours de la de la ville etc à cette
intensité programmatique on sache aussi
équilibrée et une intensité végétal avec
des bulles de biodiversité qui serait
comme peu des endroits de calme dans le
coeur de ce nouveau quartier de ville
ses intentions paysagère
environnementales urbaines
programmatique
on les a inscrites sous la forme d'un
règlement et ce règlement ensuite on a
transmises à des architectes
l'objectif était que ces architectes eux
ils transforment la règle en espace en
architecture d'abord en images et en
maquette et ensuite en chantier ensuite
arrive l'habitant on dit souvent qu'il
faut compter dix ans entre le début
d'une étude urbaine et l'arrivée des
habitants dix ans c'est long mais rome
ne s'est pas fait en un jour mais dix
ans c'est rien dans l'histoire de la
ville si on regarde cette image de voix
du xiiie siècle on remonte 800 ans en
avant et on a une image du commerce au
moyen-âge cesson et gravures réalisées
par viollet-le-duc vous avez dû en
entendre parler c'est lui qui a fait la
flèche de de notre dame
alors qu'est ce qu'on observe alors
premièrement ce qui est plutôt amusant
c'est de se voir c'est de voir que au
moyen-âge et ça existait déjà le click
and collect le client est dans l'espace
public et le marchand est derrière la
façade le lieu de l'échangé
c'est donc le percement dans la façade
alors même si vous n'êtes pas ingénieur
structure pour faire un percement dans
une façade en pierre porteuse ça ne
s'improvise pas les marchands demande
donc à des ingénieurs d'inventaire un
procédé constructif qui permettent de
maximiser les changes puisque plus il ya
d'ouverture entre le dedans et le dehors
plus il peut y avoir des changes
si on fait abstraction de l' échange
marchand dans l'histoire de la ville il
ya toujours eu un lien très étroit entre
une évolution des modes de vie et une
innovation qu'elle soit structurelle
qu'elles soient technologiques et cette
innovation va toujours dans le sens
d'une ouverture une ouverture concrète à
la rue ou une ouverture sociale à une
ouverture de liens des uns envers les
autres et finalement moi ce que je
constate c'est que le commerce de
proximité est en train de fermer que les
rues au pied de votre université sont
plutôt fermée et qu'on a presque eu
l'intention on a presque l'habitude de
fermer les yeux devant ce paysage urbain
qui se referme alors si vous aussi vous
êtes intéressés par la question et si
vous avez envie de participer à son
changement
je vous propose un chemin on va dire
qu'on peut appeler le chemin du ray deux
villes qui ferait en trois étapes la
première étape de ce chemin le
diagnostic
ouvrez les yeux et faites vous votre
propre diagnostic même si vous n'êtes
pas expert alors la question est de
dépasser le j'aime j'aime pas mais
plutôt de vous poser la question est ce
que vous vous sentez bien dans cette rue
est pourquoi vous êtes plus à l'aise ici
que là est ce que un homme est aussi à
l'aise dans un espace public qu'une
femme est ce qu'une femme est aussi à
l'aise la nuit dans cet espace public
et qu'est ce qui fait que on a un
sentiment parfois d'un confort ouvrez
les yeux dans les quartiers où vous êtes
né là où vous étudiez là où vous vivez
au quotidien
ce diagnostic fait le remonter auprès de
vos élus puisque vos élus sont nos
donneurs d'ordre c'est eux qui ensuite
peuvent prendre la décision de commander
une étude pour essayer de voir qu'est ce
que l'on pourrait améliorer dans un
quartier si vous voulez aller au delà du
diagnostic la deuxième option est celle
de l'engagement
cela vous permet de rentrer dans ce
fameux binôme dont je vous parlais en
début de conférence on pourrait
travailler ensemble à l'avenir d'un
quartier dans lequel vous allez habiter
alors vous vous souvenez ça peut prendre
quelques années avant de voir l'effet de
votre engagement mais ça ne vous empêche
pas d'avoir aussi des actions rapides
souvenez vous ces deux chaises pour
edwige et rené ont été réalisées en une
matinée et elles ont réussi à créer un
lien intergénérationnel qui n'est pas
près de se dissoudre
alors je vous demande pas à chacun de
fabriquer des chaises ça n'aurait pas
forcément de sens mais je vous demande
de réfléchir à quel est le prétexte que
vous pouvez inventé pour favoriser les
liens des liens sociaux
alors si vous avez été intéressé par un
de ces trois de l'une de ces trois
étapes dures et amour des villes eh bien
je pense que vous êtes prêts à tomber à
votre tour amoureux de votre ville
tous mes voeux de bonheur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]